[Music]
so how about this first of all welcome
our guests to all you garbage boys
to be here thank you so much absolutely
and yes if you guys don't know their
podcast it's it's the best ever check it
out that means a lot coming from you
guys thank you if you know another
podcast you're an ass wipe
um so get your head out of your ass yeah
so so I this was maybe five years ago
right I'm in LA and I and I'm wearing
that shirt today I I had a shirt that
had Ice Cube's face on it said today was
a good day okay and I put that shirt on
I like put it on in my hotel room to go
out for the day I literally first time
I'm ever wearing that shirt I'm at the
where do they do when did Whitney
Houston die is it in the tub yes in a
tupperware
um right no but but it's the Beverly
Hilton Hotel the Beverly Hilton okay um
I think it's yes the Beverly Hilton and
it's where they do like all the award
ceremonies I want to try staying in that
hotel and I walk into the elevator
literally my the door was five feet from
the elevator walk in Ice Cube is in the
elevator I swear to Christ I swear to
Christ I it just him no security nothing
just him oh my God I was on like
whatever or the 10th floor so I'm saying
nothing because I'm like what do I say
here what do I do what do I do what do I
do and he's not on like not looking at a
phone nothing he's got sunglasses on and
I go
today was a good day and then the doors
open I swear to Grass he went not for me
and walked out what was it the day that
she died no because
like today was a good day for me because
I met Ice Cube but he was like not for
me yeah oh meaning like I don't care oh
like I I might have had a bad day before
this you don't know about it I don't
know well he just said not for me and
walked out what happened when we
it's just when when I'm saying it was a
hotel Whitney Houston died yeah I
thought it was a good day it was a bad
day because he just passed away I guess
I didn't need to mention the hotel when
he used to die but I did anyway
man for being such good podcast Partners
you two are rarely on the same page and
it's my favorite thing that's what's
different about the podcast
I just I was telling him as the clip of
uh black ice coffee makes me laugh oh
yeah
I was shaking in my bed laughing yeah
who aren't on the same page and you're
still trying to figure stuff out it's so
funny that's what it is we left at the
time to Rosa came in out of nowhere when
he was talking about living living
I was talking about I was talking about
getting into stoicism and like living in
trying to obtuse now that I think about
it trying to practice poverty and just
what in practice so here here's we know
what you meant people gave you [__] you
know what you meant right and then
DeRosa saved the day with a clip but
it's interesting that whole stuff with
stoicism as you get into it again I was
just [__] in the beginning the guy
who like wrote the book this guy Ryan
holiday I speak spoke to him a little
because I was talking about so much he
was like oh [__] thanks for like
promoting my stuff and he said to me he
was like listen you're making the
mistake that everybody makes that I made
he goes and you're gonna get to it like
the stoics will say eventually it I
think the word is like don't go on airs
about meaning like don't brag about all
this self movement you're doing but you
don't know that until you start to go
into it so I'm like yeah I've been about
two months you know giving all this
advice he's like dude we all do it just
shut up now and then so now so now I'm
learning stuff but it's all inside
what's stoicism
um stoicism
[Music]
you're gonna have to figure it out
yourself it's the practice of not
telling people it's uh but did you see
that that clip where he was like he was
in here talking he's like yeah you gotta
you know don't fly for his class they
not that nice so everybody
every now and then just to practice you
know whatever you came from type things
did you say taking the subway and not
fly in first class that that's my life
[Laughter]
um so This Day Ice Cube he was talking
about January 20th 1992. so what they're
saying was
um what are they saying that uh uh well
no but they don't tell you what happened
they said the Lakers won that day that's
what you said Kev yeah they were in the
song he they took the events of the the
lyrics and were able to pin it down to
like a certain day yeah in the year
January I gotta be honest you know I'm
upset I went to this place Olsteen
olenstein Danish Bakery to get chocolate
buns for the boys and nobody wants to
eat the chocolate buns anymore we're on
a health kick dude all comedians are
healthy now we're trying man but pimpy's
back dude pimpy's [__] back on my
side now he's running out of a bun why
you bulking up I want to try to bulk up
now okay people have been no not bulk up
no you're not you're gonna leave this
journey that you're on now no I'm not
gonna look good I'm not gonna leave the
journey he eats between 1 and 1 3 but
it's been a
[Laughter]
well I think I think you know I've been
doing on a journey for a year so now
it's time to switch it up I got to do
something different I'm just getting you
know why why are you feeling like a new
no I do I do but I'm going I'm going now
I've gotten so used to I used to just be
able to not control my eating and just I
would binge constantly but now after a
year now I can go it used to be at the
16th hour 17 I'm eating and I mean but
now I'll go like before I'm eating like
a woman like a like a you know like an
aerobics instructor like I'll have like
a few bites of food every 23 hours
that's why where my family was like what
are you doing dude like you're a guy you
got to eat and I'm like I've just gotten
used to now being hungry and living in
that so now I'm just fuel up as a fat
ass that has I've lost weight before
like you know gone down that ride back
up is real fun yeah
because you're only working from a good
I got a better place
it doesn't come back right away you're
like oh I've had pizza I can eat I can
eat and then but I think you put
yourself I put myself like with real
strict rules to try to re-change the way
I think and then it's like I felt like
that's unsustainable like with social
media I was off social media for a year
but now I'm back on but not in the same
but not in the same way I was because
you have to I think at some point give
yourself some type of like or else it's
not sustainable or else you just so I'm
like let me see how good I do with now
just living a new life you know and and
not and just you know being within the
bounce see if I could be [__]
somewhat normal who knows I mean this is
gonna this is gonna get bad in a year
he's like they're only 110 calories
and the sign said
It's All Greek yogurt yeah it is 50
pounds up and down my entire life you
look good everybody's looking good so
I'm gonna I'm on a downward right now
well you look good you're you're uh uh
shredding for this for this bash yeah
what it's not it wouldn't be shredding
for the wedding what would it be for the
special shredding for the wedding Rhymes
so while you're losing weight for this
special I was happy for the species
I haven't done ozmp but no I'm just I'm
just trying to I know but I feel like
when you just say like I just I was epic
has become such a big thing that I
wouldn't even you can be on those like I
lost weight I'd say I'm you know I'm
almost impicking I don't know what I
mean I just hear everyone's on it but I
I I I should investigate I'll tell you
who needs who Aaron Rodgers you know
did this come out Thursday pimp is this
Thursday's episode I mean Aaron do you
think such a shame I mean at this point
truly like if you're a Jets or a Mets
fan it's like you'd rather root for Isis
like it's so bad right now that I
couldn't I could not believe when he
tore his Achilles because you know I
know for being a therapist that's 18
months yeah that's an 18 months yeah
you're out dude like yeah
over his career over I think you retire
after this but I also don't think this
is more than the next season then right
the two years I don't I don't think this
is the end of the line for them I think
that kid's gonna do good in their
defenses
yeah what's that Zach Wilson yeah I
think he's going to step up I mean he's
got a beautiful mind in most normal
situations that kid would have got
another year right it's just this just
worked out and by the time they get they
got the first five games and then they
got a break but off bye week if if
they're listen if they're got a winning
record by the bye week maybe but if
they're losing if they're like one in
four I think he's out and they're
talking about Tom Brady I think that's
how sick would that be talking about
he comes back and on the first plate
breaks his arm
s jbcs I'm starting to believe what the
Jets and the Mets like there because you
know I you know I was never of the mind
of believing in that stuff I'm like
that's conjecture but now I'm starting
to be like man the minds and energy of
people is really powerful I think that
if he was on another team that doesn't
this doesn't happen I think there's like
a hex that can be a fan base I gotta
think it's millions of people sending
out one it's an energy it's subconscious
I'm not saying they're actively because
it's I I I don't know I wonder if he
because he's a spiritual guy I wonder if
he believes that I wonder if you were
like I do think that there's something
about this team Thanksgiving bandages
he's a very spiritual baby yeah now let
me that that article I don't know that
spiritually but wow
[Laughter]
it's like this guy starting back in
Hollywood actresses come on he went on a
silence Retreat you think you could do
that no I think it was how many days was
that the podcast
after the patreon patreon numbers yeah I
better help the move
funny a silent podcast and every 45
minutes but patreon.com I
mean like within like six hours he's
like I was just bawling crying like
really yeah he's like because there's no
for all of this stuff you can't grab
your phone like there's there's no
energy like there's no expulsion of
energy it just all swims around in your
head imagine doing it for days you know
what we should do is the flotation tanks
you've done it I gotta I got it as a
gift three three three sessions and then
uh you have to put up the I know
[Laughter]
why would they close down and covert
that's the perfect covert activity you
buy yourself in a tank I don't know I I
don't I can't ruminate on that but they
weren't uh yeah that's not for me I
don't I'm not that's too much
love to do it yeah I saw a clip like it
was like a news story the guy went and
did it and he was like skeptical about
it and he went in there and he came out
he was bawling crying and he's like I
literally went to my childhood home and
I was walking around I didn't know it
was like that I thought you just relax a
little bit no no well it's it deprives
all it's the same thing it deprives all
senses so then your mind just oh how do
you not drown though aren't you floating
in water yeah but it's like it's very
it's super salt to order and it's like
it's only a couple inches it's extremely
buoyant got it how do you get out
is there a d knock I don't know because
if you don't know it's got to be a
release spot It's gotta be they flush
you out like a toilet
yeah can you imagine someone goes home
and doesn't unlock you
well that's the thing how am I gonna
find the exit but I'm walking around my
childhood home in 1993. how am I gonna
find you're stuck seriously you can get
stuck in there I could no way I could do
it I wanted a tanning bed no yeah that's
not to lay down the stand-up ones okay
I've done it when I was like you we used
to do it going on vacation
yeah get a nice base
New York
just to get a base a Sunday yeah Alaska
Sun Tanning on 18th Avenue
[Laughter]
and everybody was coming in there and
then when you went in you're like did
they really like wipe it down the right
way and then you the people staying in
longer and then the D they're like you
go into this one you could stay in this
one only 10 minutes because it's gonna
crisp you you go into this one you stay
in this one 22 minutes it's one kid just
telling me all the time I'm like I don't
know man I don't know about this that
was always some guy that got money that
opened up a tanning place that hired
some smoke show who he event eventually
ended up started dating and then she was
a nightmare to the other girls because
she was like in charge yeah there was no
other money behind that of like we're
gonna get a bunch of investors it was
like settlement money types yeah exactly
I got 60 Grand rights
that's the business that is like entry
level like if you get just enough
scratch I'm not sure he's just renting a
place and renting the things and then
that's it yeah it feels like the wild
west I don't think his regular relations
in that thing now they're saying and now
all the research is flipped now used to
hear sun tan and gives you skin cancer
now they're saying sunblock gives you
skin cancer now they want reverse
they're sure now they're saying where
they're saying show me the skin cancer
in the 1700s I'm like well people were
dead at 30. sure that's true but so
probably so they were all along yeah
they were long sleeves they're saying
they're dead bodies bodies yeah I'm
saying I know
I don't know filming funerals and
throwing the ones with a naked bodies
drop out coin cop TV you know that show
no no okay
I was like is this is he making all this
up now I think you should leave on
Netflix Tim Robbins yes yes
so funny dude um okay we got a quick
question people email no pressurenetwork
gmail.com some questions for the boys
for the are you garbage boys and the
babes uh can you roll your tongue this
uh Avril Moore wants to know yeah I
can't do any of that I can't even wink
which was a big thing on the show I
can't wink my left eye it's very bad can
you do both eyes okay here's the left
here's the right but I can't do without
doing that with my face subtly yeah
really you guys really sensory
deprivation over there it's like you're
winking at a kid you just banged his mom
look at my thumb we didn't do anything
thumb up like a thumbs up I can only
hold it for and then it just flips out
like like look here thumbs up I'm not
doing it it just I can't stop it like
look I can like because it's like this
and then I can connect it like that and
then I can't control when it what the
[__] is that inside steps
this guy
[__] hot dog fingers that's as long
as I can hold it and then freaky look
just pops out yeah dude that's free did
you injure that I was born like that I
was born with my thumbs flexed in on
both hands
baby like this yeah they um I've told
this before but the doctors my dad tells
me originally like the first thing
they're you know checking uh you know to
hit you in the back make sure you cry
you got the breath sounds you get all
that they're calling out all these
different things everything's good and
then one of the nurses was like uh no no
thumbs
hahaha
money
I swear and then and then my dad says
he's like this is no thumbs and then my
dad turned him it's like what and then
one of the I guess the doctor came over
and like checked and they flipped over
my hand they're like no his thumbs just
flexed in we can pull out of some and
then for the first like that's playing
fast and lose yeah she was a little
eager with that yeah he's got penguin
hands everybody run his hands look like
a Tostitos she should have even kicked
into first base like can you make the
call yeah another set of eyes hit on
that and then for that they just had to
do little exercises with my thumbs like
little things that's why you got in a
physical therapy seriously dude my mom
would do it because my my mom was like
your father just wouldn't do it sure
he's like I'm not doing that so she
would just have to pull my thumb back
um but I can't roll my tongue this is
how long my tongue is not I'm not even
kidding
a moment
yeah my tongue looks like it's been
amputated he's got a big one let me see
it whoa
I can't roll it down you can use
yourself
yeah yeah like oh that's that you can't
do something I can't do that either I
can do that
make a burrito but I think they're
talking about twisting it oh no there
was a girl in high school that could do
it man still got her number yeah which
yeah that's the best I don't know um
what about these people and they're
they're out there sure back in time
Cherry stuff that's crazy with their
tongue yeah yes how how
people are talented there's not enough
dexterity I think it's only only people
can do that are strippers and nail
technicians
or tanning salon for us yeah I mean that
freaks me out dude yeah what are you
doing what is your tongue doing that
you're taking two ends of a stem it's
looping them and tying I would have to
assume and this is just based on nothing
really it's kind of it's probably like
the Rubik's Cube once you know how to do
it it's probably like a handful of
simples
about solving a Rubik's Cube with your
tongue
there's a viral video yeah but I'll tell
you something right now I want to talk
about better help right now this show is
sponsored by better help and I I have
been
laying in bed a lot and my mind is
racing I cannot stop my mind it makes me
I cannot fall asleep and here's the
thing
therapy
you get everything on your mind out you
kind of vent you get it out and I I see
that when I have a therapy session I
usually get sleep that night right does
it happen yes if I have stuff pent up
with stuff I need to get off my chest
and stuff that's bothering me yeah the
second my head hits the pillow that's
all I'm thinking about yeah better help
it's the thing you think like oh it's
only helping me in the moment when I'm
doing a therapy but it's helping you
it's like all throughout the day the
next day it's like changing the way you
think and if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try what I
love about it it's done entirely online
yeah convenient flexible suited to your
schedule you don't have to worry about
going to an actual office all online and
all you do is fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist you can switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge they literally make it so simple
for you to just get the therapy that you
need so get a break from your thoughts
with better help right visit
betterhelp.com hey babe yes today to get
10 off of your first month that's better
help
help.com hey babe that's what you got do
betterhelp.com hey babe 10 off your
first month it's beautiful guys
September 23rd theater at Madison Square
Garden there are a few tickets left
Chris D comedy.com New York City
Christie weekend September 22nd Radio
City sold out and then September 30th
the cosmo in Vegas christiecomedy.com
for all the other dates
guys this is the biggest announcement
I've made in history of this podcast
okay I've been teasing this for years
and finally uh my special taping in
Chicago at the Vic theater uh on
December 2nd is on sale finally right
this second today is pre-sale you can go
on right now and get tickets before
anybody else if you use the code no
pressure one word
n-o-p-r-e-s-h you're gonna get the
better seats right this second tomorrow
they go on sale to the general public I
can't wait to see you there I'm so
excited and I am so excited that I want
to do something for you I'm going to
pick one winner and let them have a plus
one out of all the attendees of the
shows to fly to New York I'm gonna put
you up in a hotel and I'm gonna take you
on the set of Impractical Jokers with me
so all you got to do is come to the
special if you're in it you're eligible
to win I just want to do something back
for you guys because you supported me
this whole time so get your tickets get
a chance to win I hope I see you in
Chicago that's the thing I could never I
can never do that ever my nephew is uh
he's 16. oh 10 years old solved the
Rubik's cube right solves it he can
solve it at any time yeah it's
unbelievable he went home he sent me a
picture he solved it he's ten that's
crazy and not one side every side well
because because the thing is I watched
my stepson do it he's been doing it for
a couple of years like he just saw and
he got he's got he saws it went from it
went from when he first got when he
first started getting them for him it
was like let's call two minutes now he
could solve them in 10 to 15 seconds
even when you give him because he said
it's not you're looking at we all think
oh I'm looking at this we don't know how
to look at it it's all it's all an
algorithm it's all six clicks up six
clicks down three so he says once you
figure it out you do it these kids these
speed Rubik's Cube kids they do it in
three seconds yeah two seconds slash a
dock on it it's pretty wild yeah and he
feels like a loser because he could do
it in 15 seconds he's like I'll never be
anything I'll never get the girls
all right here we go we got another
email from uh Joseph from a star
garbage class you're crazy public
restroom taking a [__] do you rip off
the most recent part of the toilet paper
roll knowing the person before you is
using it or leave it I rip off the
bottom throw it right on the ground for
a fresh portion of the toilet paper
I mean I respect it I respect yes I
throwing it on the ground throw it on
the ground's a little distance touching
it just throw it in the toilet yeah just
I but what I will say is a public
restroom What I've Done away with now is
setting up the entire toilet paper
smiley face thing I'm done with that I
give it a nice wipe with the toilet
paper and then I just put my ass yeah
[__] of your thighs if it looks okay a
wipes flush you always flush even if
it's sitting sure flush it get that down
and then you wipe it around the bowl and
then you just sit right on the ball
Sal's saying no yeah I'll tell you right
now not only do I not do that I do the
thing three four layers deep are you
then you hover you can't get it you
can't get a spread on that I need a
spread I need the I need to spread my
cheeks on the plastic the paper wouldn't
do it it would just slide oh I see yeah
I need a spread okay and I stopped doing
this recently but for a while what I
would do real bad because in my head
once you flush the toilet that water was
somewhat clean I would take a little
bunch of toilet paper dip it in the
water in the toilet and use that to wipe
the seat and then throw the toilet paper
down and then flush it insane and then
sit and then sit on it yeah and then sit
on without a layer yeah you made it
worse yeah
what might have been on there and
ensuring that it is yeah I did that up
until about a year ago wow yeah that
that is actually like I'm surprised you
have you haven't gotten like a massive
infection nobody does dude nobody's
getting anything from toilets it's like
what you're saying it's all it's all
yeah they're taking toilet toilet seat a
toilet inside of a toilet bowl are very
different things yeah just because yeah
because the water it gets the [__] and
pissed previously out but I mean they're
still all germs everywhere it's all over
that bathroom
I touch it
throw the germs on it that's true but
that's a classic I like that that is
classic the kid the kid the kid does he
does he does seem classy mine looks like
a ticket parade in there four layers in
the trunk in a triangle and then I take
an extra big layer that I roll like this
and this is just to take a piss
and then just to wash his hands and then
I take it and you know what in the front
where it's like sure that's where they
get you get you yeah so what where the
Gap is so you take you take that big
thing and you do enough it's big enough
that you lay it over the top of it
almost like a saddle no yeah I know it
you know sure and then and then I got
Barber's rag yeah I [__] my pants
and then I put a ton of toilet paper in
the bowl so nothing splashes but why
this is like fine
yeah it's like an emergency only you
don't do away games no no no no no no
what about here I don't even like do it
in hotels what yes how do you get a
knife in a nice hotel maybe you know
maybe but if you're away for the weekend
no no in a nice hotel I you know if I
gotta but yeah no I mean I don't like
doing it I don't like what about here
dude you [__] in the shower no I never
no I never had to here luckily I've
already but can I tell you
[Laughter]
do those same rules apply to the women's
bathroom uh yeah 100 really yeah lick
the seat in there yeah that's
interesting the women's bathroom is most
that's a clean Place atrocious the
women's bathroom is usually much worse
than that no dude I'm telling you I've
been into my share women's bathrooms
they are
disgusting people will girls will leave
periods they'll leave shits popping out
of the explanation yes a mess sure I get
that seriously men because a lot of
times men were just peeing but women you
know you're because I think it was a
woman you got to sit down on the ball so
listen even if I don't have to crap if
I'm sitting on the ball take a pee some
poop will come out and I think that's
what happens with women they're sitting
down I mean that seems like a medical
problem dude yeah but men are Reckless
with the pee they don't they don't put
chicks have started doing that now more
and more than they used to well because
they they score
thank God for that yes
baby they don't they think yeah they
don't uh they don't they won't sit and
they'll just they'll just they'll just
spray it depends on the
the location if it's a nice joint Ryan
the lobby to a nice hotel no one's
spread like you you keep the company
you're with let me say this though if I
ever go to pee in a stall and any drips
get anywhere I I clean that thing fully
before I walk out really yeah of my own
drips oh yeah really yeah I like that a
hundred percent I'd get a big bowl
I'm being courteous no I'll flip deceit
to make it seem like it wasn't me
ah I'll go like this with if I do get a
couple dribbles on the seat yeah the
seat goes up with my foot yeah I go out
don't wash my hands what about this is
a dirtbag move probably if I'm peeing in
a urinal let's call it the airport I'm
painting your own I'm chewing gum but
the gum's done I'll spit the gum into
the urine I don't like it it's not
classy but it's a dirt bag someone's got
clean
they got to clean that away though yeah
but yeah I mean yeah
there's gum in there I'm probably aiming
at it yeah of course
yeah that's on per you know the little
flies in the urinal yeah that's on
purpose that's on purpose so Splash yeah
so men aim at something because before
that men would truly like piss all over
the walls yeah I read about it oh yeah
no it is I think it's the I think it's
Toto is the brand that has the yeah Toto
which means in Spanish so every time you
see that I'm just like you're calling me
oh yeah which means hey babe in Spanish
oh yeah this is a clean podcast kids we
don't curse tell the ad sponsors so I
think I've cursed 80 times already
you've said hey babe anytime okay oh all
right we're gonna drop hey baby
garbage I love the smell of the ornament
love the smell interesting a lot like
love if I get a fresh one I'll be on it
to activate wow to get it up and
[Laughter]
my buddy growing up they made a bunch of
money they were poor they made a bunch
of money and they all lost it after that
but they put a huge addition sounds like
the story that are you Garbage Guys
big urinal and steam room and man I
thought you couldn't tell me nice urinal
pretty awesome luxury it's probably
that's the price of a toilet I mean why
is it like uh wiggle you have to install
my family uh uh owns a plumbing company
so you'll have to install two fixtures
okay because you can't just have a
urinal right all right otherwise the
toilet serves both but it's so funny
because this is funny
I'm waiting for I'm having parties yeah
when you go to a nice restaurant and you
walk into the bathroom and it's a real
nice bathroom they have the that's the
best beautiful okay nice clean how about
they have Linens
they have a candle burning in there yeah
I like when I walk into a bathroom in a
restaurant I think two things could I
poop in here and it's just a safe space
to how about this I want yeah do a
little blow yeah
I went to a nice I went to a nice place
one of my friends one of my you know
Queen's trash friends sure went to a
nice restaurant
in L.A they came out me and Alex a few
years ago we go nice you know classy
Place Italian place go bathroom
beautiful bathroom like you're
describing you know they had those
washcloths to wash your hands sure eat
and whatever all good and then we're
leaving and he goes what did you guys do
with the washcloths after you used them
oh no and I said uh
what do you mean just watch your hands
he goes yeah but you wipe your ass with
that where did you put that I said you
wiped your ass with the hand claws he
was like well I what else are they for
and I was like what about the toilet
paper next to the toilet he's like I
didn't even notice that so he washed his
hands he wiped his ass with the
washcloths that you were supposed to dry
your hands with just piece of [__] he
said he just threw him in there was a
basket a basket for the driveway
oh God I mean why would you join streams
[Laughter]
I do have a favorite urinal in New York
City okay it's at Gallagher's Steakhouse
in Times Square Midtown whatever it is
they're huge they're from like the 19
like 18. so they're like the size of you
and like oh they're they're standing
there
this one yeah where they go on the floor
those are nice yeah because yeah but you
you're gonna get a piss on your shoes
for sure for the experience
if you look at those historically those
will have a nice a bigger puddle around
them than the other oh for sure let me
ask you this will you use the little one
the shorter one I've used it yeah I
don't mind it you know what I don't mind
it recently I should know this again my
family owns a plumbing company and I've
installed them I always thought they
were for children yeah no handicap
that's why the Wall's there because the
the wheelchair can't get close children
not for children very interesting
somebody about the handicapped people on
the phone because children are co-opting
now yes but it is an ADA toilet wow so
so the height is 99 the height is
Justice you can be in a wheelchair and
that's why the Wall's there because you
can't get up on it so it's always
there's always going to be a barrier
that makes sense on this kid why I
always thought it was the kid one do you
remember Uncle Buck though yeah when he
goes into anneals yeah it was a great
piece of Comedy that makes sense right
here yeah interesting listen if you're
missing the sear for your pancakes or
you just ran out of your favorite coffee
creamer doordash grocery delivery gets
you what you want right when you need it
you've trusted doordash to Olivia
restaurant favorites and now you can get
grocery delivery that actually delivers
too I mean babe you forgot they'll give
you new sunglasses it's just as big
people think of doordash is ordering
food man the grocery stuff look burnt
your last piece avocados coped right yes
delivery when you need it right to your
door that's that's basically you'll get
exactly what you ordered or they'll make
it right sit back enjoy your quality
groceries and if you want more value you
can save on all the grocery and
restaurant favorites with a zero dollar
delivery fee on eligible orders with the
dash pass membership for our
Spanish-speaking members that's settle
settle dollar settle get fifty percent
5-0 off your first doordash order up to
twenty dollar value when you use code
babe fall that's b-a-b-e-f-a-l-l at
checkout limited time offer terms apply
that's 50 off up to twenty dollars no
minimum subtotal and zero delivery fees
on your first order when you download
the doordash app in the app store and
enter code babe fall don't forget yeah
that's babe fall for 50 off your first
order with doordash babe game time
that's where you got to buy your tickets
from tickets for anything comedy events
concerts sporting events game time buy
tickets to your favorite events it
should not be stressful game time makes
it fast easy it's the best way to buy
tickets to anything killer deals on last
minute tickets and the best price
guarantee yeah that's where they Thrive
last minute tickets at the lowest prices
guaranteed if you find uh the same seat
in your row or section on another place
for Less they will refund they will
credit you they will credit you 110 the
difference you also could see your seat
they show you the seat view from where
you're sitting it's two clicks to buy it
gets sent to your phone not your email
all the last minute stuff there's the
best deals that you could find download
the game time app today
um snag the tickets without the stress
with Game Time download the game time
app today create an account and use code
hey babe for 20 off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account
redeem the code hey babe for twenty
dollars off download game time today on
get it's gametime.co by the way yes
gametime.co last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed we gotta get we got to
step it up with uh Japanese so the
Japanese now if you piss in the toilets
near they they will send the they
analyze your medical data and they'll
send an email to your doctor's office
and tell you if you're sick or not she's
just being in the toilet too I don't
know yeah
dude will you
much better in Japan here we go Tyler C
hey babes here's my cue would you rather
be shrunken down to Tiny size or become
giant size
um I mean it's because this world isn't
even built for someone who's six eight
it's not built for either one I know but
what's giant size yeah
it's nine feet
it's nine feet are you doing my like a
four feet tiny size or shiny I Shrunk
the Kids in my head when I hear Giant
and Tiny I go nine feet two feet okay
okay two nine feet two sure yeah like my
two-year-old people up nine feet yeah
you do you can't sleep in a bed you
can't drive in a car well man you get
all that [__] custom made yeah
money who's gonna hire you what are you
talking about if you're nine feet tall
I'll just walk into a bank and [__]
take it I'm not gonna fit in the safe I
will push two mattresses together sure I
I think I I want to be nine feet because
I we could dunk yeah
two feet the world's not gonna chew up
and spit you out like it's crazy you
can't walk around at two feet No One's
Gonna Die
for women at nine feet yeah oh yeah of
course yeah yeah I think I'd I'd like a
good point I'd go tiny but but what is
the advantage give me one advantage of
walking around you is two feet tall
stealthiest
nine feet you can't hang out at like
it comes to you you don't gotta go to
bars I think the guy who's two feet more
than the guy who's nine feet I think the
girl you'll a guy who's two feet more
sex than the guy who's nine I think the
women are scared of nine but the two
foot fun they're having to find out
that's a bucket list item also not a
nine foot girls are scared of nine not
the videos I watch
[Laughter]
yeah yeah what can you do
I don't know I might walk I might go
find all the people around me maybe slap
them around yeah you become a bully
which I'm not at heart so I don't know
I'm not a timid boy so I'd like to make
two feet maybe intimidate them because
just just because they did it sure yeah
the Robin Hood of bullies stand up right
the bullies right right husband abandons
wife during connecting flight for being
late and the internet is taking his side
I mean we were just talking about this
big fan of that no I'm not a big fan of
it not even this instant but we travel a
lot for work obviously like you know
you're on the road you're zipping around
and when you're working I we operate we
travel together and you
you guys travel in packs as well you got
a couple people with you usually got a
couple people with you they're not
lollygagging they're they're just
freaking Mission yes at hand yeah I just
got back from Greece with my girl and I
hadn't flown anywhere with her in this
is what you're talking about right yes I
hadn't flown it with her in maybe like a
year I think the last time we went away
and everything after that and before
that has been [__] for work and man
it's like we're walking around the
[__] Sunday serenade I'm like let's
go because she'd have clear and TSA
pre-check and all that or do you have to
because you have it right with all the
traveling I have I have TSA preaching
does she have it she has Global Entry
okay what she left me coming back to JFK
she went through Global Entry which I
wanted it does it's pointless because my
lady doesn't have it and it's a whole to
do to get it I go through I'm standing
on the other side waiting for it I leave
my wife every single time we get to TSA
you're on your own I told you for two
years to do this for it I'm not taking
my gosh darn shoes off I'm talking about
multiple times blow out fights me
waiting on the not TSA line to just keep
her company where two times in my life
she has walked away from our lug and
said I'm going home well this is nothing
because you're mad this is what I've
learned you're mad that you're not in
the TSA preaching yes and so you're
better off not being next to her you
think I'm keeping her company but you're
ruining the trip but yeah but then she
gets mad at me if I'm not then I've left
her and I've abandoned her
I try to do this all the time but but
now she finally has TSA pre-check she
just finally got it and clear because
it's almost like it's almost like a
relationship clear all right I was drunk
so I got clear yeah so I wasn't sure if
I was gonna be able to read my eyes
the global entry is the one buddy I felt
like I was coming through Ellis
yeah it was a Friday night they had
three people three three [__] uh
customs
[Laughter]
I even told her I said hey I'm gonna be
an hour if you got the luggage once you
take a car go ahead and get yourself
home and get situated I'll meet you
there that's enough
luggage shakes out though you know
sometimes it's just waiting in that line
waiting in that line and I would do that
after a long flight I wanted to walk up
to one of these guys you'd be like this
is an embarrassment to the country
that's how [__] mad I was because in
Greece
they're serving Spanish
they don't give a [__] nuts this but the
this guy leave like to actually take off
on the plane without his wife and son
yeah that's crazy I understand I
understand the anger yeah I mean yeah
that I I get that but if you just got on
the plane and your wife and son are not
on the plane yet and they're coming on
the plane what's yeah you I couldn't do
that I would take their bags for them
put them up okay so what happened here
is she wanted to get Starbucks and he
was like I'm not doing it you're joking
yeah she wanted to get Starbucks he's
like I'm not doing it and he just
boarded the plane without her and what
the plane left listen that listen I
don't know if the plane left yeah I
don't know if he did that but that are
you [__] kidding so that's what I'm
talking about we're the plane has
already started to board oh now granted
we were in [__] main seven or
whatever it was in the back of the plane
she's like oh I want to get some snacks
now no I'm like what are you doing yeah
you lost your chance you blew it yeah
yeah come on Starbucks lady I got yeah I
got a huge ball I'll travel with my lady
uh but you know we were flying first
class get coffee on the plane Starbucks
where were we going uh good first class
because sometimes you get first class
and it's a [__] yes it's a [__]
you might as well you might as well not
have gone the first one always I don't
care I'll pay more I don't I'll spend
all of my money you just do it I don't I
can do it I cannot do it I travel too
much I'm in the back my personal trip
see I only travel first class when I'm
going for work because I'm like I'm what
but but with the family I I just sit and
Coach no I said even what I don't have I
mean it's just me I'm not rolling with
30 Puerto Ricans hahaha
here are those donuts got the grill
going back there oh yeah oh yeah I got a
dobo in every bag
of the air breaks out yeah somebody's
back there cupping up mangoes
it's all right we're good but I was like
no she we were at the they were getting
ready to board I have a big I have
anxiety I just want to get on the plane
I hate to get on plane first I'm going
to make sure okay I want to put my stuff
in I want to sit down I want to order a
club whatever it is that is what I'm
paying this is for me not losing it
because I'm gonna lose it I know I'm
gonna lose it I respect yourself
and we're waiting and they're like okay
you know active military anybody that
needs a hand I'm like well we're getting
called which I could take advantage of
and I don't I want that on my record the
military no no no no
I'm in a war with comedy if I walked if
they said active military and people who
need extra assistance and I walked up
they wouldn't bat an eye okay fair
enough maybe now that you're trimming up
yeah that's the thing dude you're gonna
lose some privileges
no not no you know what they do though
what annoys me and continue your thing
but they make group one more than first
class so when you spring for the ticket
you're like all right I'm gonna pay this
extra money off some comfort I'll get on
first they do all those people people
with kids people that need help people
out of their military all 1K members
get real loosey-goosey with the
qualifications and then they just go
uh a boarding group one and it's like
you're gonna be assertive already paid
for the first class I'm boarding with
everybody
's gonna agree with this but I'd like to
make a statement I do think that
people paying for first class we paid
extra money it's tough especially in
today's economy to have people walk past
the people sitting in first class it's
not fun I think that what airline should
do back at the plane let them let groups
two three four five board first they
can't put any old thing in the overhead
luggage you can't [__] touch it
class we board last nobody sees
people start coming down even versus we
fly 300 times a year you're only talking
about work I'm not talking now
you just said you're in the back of the
plane yeah
I'll put my foot down on this I agree
with you yeah not because I don't want
people age a man that is since I'm 13
years old yes I will if I'm if I'm
paying cash out of my pocket for the
first class ticket I'm fine with that
it's I'll I will never go to the back of
the plane I think I think that should be
the case that you they should board the
back not because I care people when when
we are lucky enough to be in the front
people walk by me but it makes so much
more sense logistical sense yeah like
everyone just get off just staggerating
stagger the gay times they they do one
group one
first
okay then two because if you can't do
five because then they're gonna use the
luggage they use the luggage in the back
I know but the way
you just safe these days no
no no I've I've missed the initial for
boarding group one and got on a little
bit late in that and everybody the six
seats up there where I'm flying over in
Pittsburgh they're all taken already
yeah and they're like we're gonna need
to check that I'm like I don't mind the
gate check though you get it right when
you get off the plane what's the big
deal sometimes you got to wait 10-15
minutes around with everybody else when
you could be running getting to the
bathroom getting to that Uber
outside I will tell you as much as you
can and I know it's hard especially
going on long trips but I have to go to
San Diego just for one day last week and
I went with just a book bag so no I did
not need the overhead sure it feels like
a different you feel like I felt like I
was driving like I let everybody get on
it I'll walk in a second before you
close the door I have no problems my
seat's right there right under the seat
that was amazing you're like a nomad a
person who walks through place to place
in search of foreign
every show and I wore the same shirt
three times I could have easily all I
needed workout shoes I could have easily
gotten away with stuff in a book bag I
we don't need all this stuff when we
when we we go on the road and a lot of
times now we get airbnbs instead of
hotels nice moves cheaper buddy I bring
like four shirts that's it just do a
couple loads he has to do launches
oh yeah I mean but that's why it's good
to get an Airbnb do the laundry do a
little laundry I started doing only the
pants I'm wearing only the shoes I'm
wearing
I have a travel set of shoes and I have
a show shoes all right I tried I've
tried the same ones no gym shoes
brings his Peloton shoes now let me ask
you guys a question I know this is
inside comedy but I know I don't ask
comedians this a lot when you're on the
road all right what is your routine do
you guys wake up at noon one o'clock do
you see the city do you walk around do
you treat it like a vacation where
you're seeing the town no it's different
for us we do one nighters literally
Wednesday Thursday three different
cities but still but you but you don't
see the city like you don't want to get
to the city or like for example I just
did Portland and Seattle right and I
said right after the show in Portland I
want to drive to Seattle get in Seattle
at midnight because I want to wake up at
8am and see the city yeah and then do
the show at night but some guys would be
like I'm gonna wake up at one o'clock in
Portland and then get to Seattle right
before the show and not care so are you
guys next week next week we're waking up
we're flying to Arizona Zona doing a
show waking up flying to Denver doing a
show doing two shows waking up flying to
Salt Lake City doing a show okay and
then waking up and flying down
with the airports that's impossible if
you're flying it's impossible yeah
that's too tough but when we do have
time and if we do the most we'll have
when we get to a city the most time
we'll have is maybe three hours before
we have to get back in the car to get to
the show to do soundtrack you can't do
anything real you can't because you're
like also I want to be fret like the job
and it goes back to the Flying first
classic my wife convinced me she's like
you you're the shot like you're the this
is your job like you have to be as fresh
as possible at 7 pm every night right so
if I can if that means like we don't get
to walk around the city or like we chill
for two hours or whatever it's like
that's what it is
no when I first started traveling like
that and and and and the few times that
the guy's not like on a bus is different
but like I I did it because it was like
my first time in a lot of these states
right and I used to just push it but
this was like you know 15 years ago now
I I I literally literally get there as
late as possible with one backup flight
and I come home as early as possible and
I'm usually 95 of the time when I'm in
bed right after the lesson I don't know
why because I'm saying you know I've
been to these places a lot but like when
I just went to Portland you know came to
Portland I went to LA Portland Seattle
like I was exploring more like I was
like you know what let me just go out
and walk yeah something's happened with
my mindset lately where I used to like
want to work out and like be sore but
now I'm like you know what dude if I
could just get like a two-hour walk-in
like this light cardio I I swear to God
like for the first time in my life and I
know that it's real because it's been
like three months and I've let go of
being ripped I'm like I don't care I
don't I I just want to feel good so I'm
like let me just like walk around
yeah
and I dude let me tell you something
Portland the great people of Portland
rev Hall in Portland dude that venue it
was on fire they were unbelievable
because I think cities that are like you
know stereotypically extremely liberal
they bring out the Counter Culture in
comedy and they bring out people who
aren't offended by anything so it's like
you know it's not even a liberal
Republican thing it's just you think
that people in Portland would be
offended sure
it's the opposite I will say they
compare Portland and Seattle they say
they're both like War zones with uh you
know like poverty everywhere I'm like no
no Portland there's human [__] in the
streets everywhere downtown Seattle had
a couple of blocks Seattle though is
like gorgeous yeah holy crap it's like
the Emerald City oh my God so green
dudes in the rain that's really cool
beautiful people best best looking
Asians I've ever seen in my life there
you go men and women and you can still
get a nice bag of H if you want one
that's it dude there you go dude
Japanese people are beautiful we don't
have a lot of Japanese in New York if
you see a joke
they just look different we talked about
this they're gorgeous especially babies
Japanese no we said Asian babies Asian
babies the best Asian baby one black
baby too yeah
I've never seen an ugly Asian or black
baby not wrong you are not they are very
very beautiful the best Tiger Woods most
beautiful baby of all time sure half
black half Asia
just saying dude do you know Tiger Woods
trained to be a Navy SEAL after he after
yeah that's why he hurt his back when he
started to get all the injuries and all
that stuff it's because he was Navy SEAL
training when his dad died his dad was a
Green Beret in Vietnam and he like had
like this wait wait after he was Tiger
Woods though he was Tiger he already won
he was he already won Master tournament
he was fully Tiger Woods and he showed
up to Navy SEAL training like he was in
Tiger Woods well like the guy section
like Tiger Woods and yeah he has spent
time training with the elite Navy Seals
in in 2006 his dad was a Green Beret in
Vietnam and he said he had like a snap
in his brain he was like yeah I'm doing
it I'm being I'm gonna make my dad proud
you want to get Jesus Christ
I wouldn't do that but then he might be
like I gotta do something together they
couldn't send him on missions if he got
captured no there's probably just the
training well
he wasn't gonna oh he wasn't gonna join
I don't know I think he won was he not
picked it he didn't he's gonna take out
yeah but that's when SEAL Team Six hit
him with a nine iron
[Laughter]
yeah he's going he's going for his
record I always felt like if I saw Tiger
Woods like if I had gotten to a scuffle
with him or a little bit of a dust up I
feel like I could kind of play for you
living okay that's what you're thinking
about it
when I did that I thought about him and
I feel like I could probably
fight him nah
pretty big no I know he'll probably
really beat me but what I'm saying the
idea what I'm saying is I look at him as
like kind of a a frail gun
he's very quiet it just seems like he
seems like a push-up can you what could
you no yes
when the chips
at least one Haymaker is Gonna Fly
no he's ripped but you know what I mean
he just feels like thin and like polite
well he was thin for a long time and
then got jacked and his earlier in his
career he was he was significantly how
old is he
um that hairline's 60 Seconds
so is mine 47. 47. same age he's one
year old and 11 wait he's 11 months
older than me okay yeah I don't know I'm
the same age you're 47 yeah we'll be
nice you're 47 47. good age 77 43 yeah
you're the dragon baby
are you 39. I'm 39. oh you're 37. yeah
Oh I thought Airlines wrong I thought
that you guys were closer in age that's
why I said that he's just gross the
third so were you 1986. really 1986
[Music]
you think so no actually you probably
could 10 years younger you're fit now
true right like right now you're you're
the Finish you probably I could beat him
in a fasting contest
hunger strike I'll crush them
what about Bradley Cooper do you think
Bradley Cooper no because I think that
the thing no but I think the thing that
you take I think the thing that you
don't understand with actors is that all
those fighting scenes and stuff that
they learn they actually learn how to
Reeves would [__] somebody up I would
assume it's probably it's probably
pretty
by the way on the plane coming back
speaking of uh Bradley Cooper I watched
you know I've seen it a million times
but I haven't seen a while Wedding
Crashers again that is he's so good the
funniest movie there has not been a
comedy
vicinity in the last like 15 years like
it does they do not exist no it laugh
out loud
tie away and he was so good because you
hate it like he played that character so
well it was so good it looked five
inches shorter in that too he was he
looked shorter and stockier I haven't
watched it since it came out
I'm telling you it's like a re-watch
tonight like you will you will I just
watched it last week no you will die
like the beginning scenes but she like
certain things goes you shut your mouth
when you're talking to me oh my God
an old lady made you play with her jugs
who cares yeah a couple of kids who want
to fight even like motor like do you
know you know what motor boating is like
that's from them
there's so many things that I was
already a thing no it wasn't something
that's a movie it might have been a
thing but it wasn't I was in first place
I heard it just like in Along Came Polly
when Philip Seymour Hoffman says to Ben
Stiller
the American the public never heard
those terms before I heard it from there
but I didn't know if they did so that's
it made it up that's not about a great
performance
I personally think wedding crashes is
one I'll give you one of the most
underrated comedies in the last 10 years
good boys have you seen it good boys
it's a rated R comedy about three best
friends in the fifth grade it is laugh
out loud funny from beginning oh it's
with actual kids yeah oh I saw the
coming track yeah okay I remember it is
so funny I've seen it I've watched it
ten times all right and you laugh out
loud that's a whole thing it's I don't
even have to you won't come back to me
like that wasn't funny it's undeniable
and this was made in 2019 so it can be
done yeah it's just who wrote it was it
so good the guy he was like I think he's
one of the guys from the office I think
Lee Eisenberg maybe okay so that's a
good one I haven't seen Seth Rogen had
something to do with it
he's amazing but all those guys want
they listen to the pots they know and um
God bless them then did you guys see
before we go did you guys see did we
talk about this this secret uh living to
100 the secrets to um it's on Netflix uh
the secrets of the blue zones living to
100. I've seen the living to 100. the
place that everyone uh is living like
yes pimpy can you pull it up Netflix uh
Blue Zone show it's on right now it just
came island or something where
everyone's like there's five of them
five or six blues live to 100 secrets of
the blue zones dude this show was
fascinating so I didn't know that he
goes and talks to five different groups
of centenarians people who live to 100
you know whatever yeah
[Music]
and then
so what what's interesting about it is
they because because you know I've been
living on where I live in Staten Island
it's like very Suburban right very
Suburban doesn't have sidewalks and it's
beautiful but I'm like you know I don't
I I started to feel something I'm like I
just don't like it here I feel like I'm
getting lonely here I feel unhealthy
here whatever and then they talk about
and that was just a feeling it was just
in my head and then when I'm watching
the show and they ask one group I think
it was in Japan they were like what is
like the secret for you and they were
like we all live in close communities
and we have sidewalks they were like
this town our town didn't have sidewalks
and people were dying and now we have
sidewalks to get to the Village because
they said the reason why you'll see it's
like you're also killing the average
Kevin everybody that why you'll see you
know like when you go to a town old
school European town or I guess Japanese
Town everybody's like you know you're
like Community
interpersonal relations because the
suburbs was an American invention the
suburbs wasn't in a thing in other parts
of the world the suburbs we invented
them because after World War II we had
all this you know automotive power we
had built all these tanks and stuff that
were just laying there so the automotive
industry said we got to get people in
these freaking cars so they came up the
idea of the suburbs all the Levitt towns
you would see this that it's all the
military so how do we get people in the
cars that we have that we built driving
out there and then they sold this idea
of the American dream picket fence in
the suburbs but it kills you how our
obesity rate of course adds to it but
also the way we live in the suburbs no
good so that's why it just gave me
motivation to sell my house I was like
I'm going back to the city baby wait
what are these five different places
around the world where people live what
are the towns the things uh Newark yeah
yeah right next to the bank
Delaware yeah
it was a county well there uh also an
outliers you know uh Malcolm glad you
ever read outliers yeah Malcolm Gladwell
yeah I think the opening story of that
uh about like kind of what promotes all
of that stuff is I think it was outliers
uh is this town in Pennsylvania was I
think they were Greek or Italian they
were all it was all they were all
derived from this town in Greece or
Italy and they they lived to like the
average age was like 98 years old it was
because of inner but it was like one
side of the Hill live to this and the
other side was dying at like 60. well
they said it was some of the big thing
there's a variety of foods the thing
they all have in common is cooking at
home cooking at home and take in light
physical activity they're all gardening
or walking it's all down in Italy
activity is where I live
right now you guys gotta you guys got a
a hard out I like something like a
casual wall you want to double up on
this where are we at
now you guys do you have anywhere to go
you want to keep flowing we're chilling
baby can I send a text real quick don't
send it right now on the show because
it's all it's all contact
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings
[Music]